Brian uh I'm not a cosmologist my
background's in Neuroscience but I've
been following cosmology for you know 40
years or more and what's I have found
fascinating is over the last I don't
know a couple of decades decade there
has been more of a challenge to the
standard model of inflation than had
been before inflation of course had to
break this breakthrough in 1980-ish with
Alan Guth and and then people in Russia
Andre Linde and became a standard model
but then suddenly became a lot of
different attacks and they looked
peripheral and now they the attacks or
the different approaches look more
Central so as a professional you feel
follow the field give me a sense of
what's really happening on the inside
yeah so the important thing to know
about inflation then and it's
discontents
is that it it was kind of the dominant
player in the marketplace of ideas for
as you say for the last 40 years and to
some it still is yeah the question is is
that healthy for the market a place of
ideas to have monopolistic overtaking of
it by a single idea I would argue no
it's not healthy it doesn't mean
inflation is wrong the question is what
could supplant it that doesn't have the
kind of difficult features that
inflation puts in by hand in some cases
to explain the peculiar features that
were missing the lacune in The Big Bang
Theory so in science the misconception
is you know we prove things no we don't
prove things we look for Flaws we look
for cracks and that's how the light gets
in and we hope to understand better the
flaws in the currently accepted you
could call it a paradigm so inflation
was created as a way to patch some of
the gaps some of that Kune in the Big
Bang model which were known for a long
long time several of them at the same
time simultaneously and it's
spectacularly successful at that it
wasn't predicted at priori it wasn't
predicted out of you know within Arizona
and so I think it has some remarkable
success go go through quickly which are
the the things the flatness are right
yeah so right so the uh the original
kind of motivation for Alan Guth when he
began this investigation 1979 as a
postdoc about to become unemployed so he
needed some uh some help uh it was to
patch up a hole which suggested that the
Universe should be suffused with what
are called magnetic monopoles which are
artifacts relics of an early hot dense
evolutionary phase of the universe when
it transitioned from different phases of
domination from radiation domination
matter domination and different phase
transitions called the Electra weak
phase transition when the forces
separate and become as the energy went
down as the energy that goes down the
universe cools so many particle
physicists and particle cosmologists
thought there should be plenty of these
magnetic monopoles we don't see any of
them why is that so the monopole problem
was known for quite some time the other
major successes of inflation were to its
ability to explain things like the
flatness so-called flatness of the
universe which is why out of an infinite
number of possibilities of positively
curved it's like a ball or a sphere or
negatively curved like a pringle chip
there's an infinite number of positive
curvatures there's an infinite number of
negative curvatures there's only one
zero zero is unique zero means flat why
is the universe flat why did it pick the
one element out of an infinite double
infinite infinite negative infinite
positive that happens to be what we
observe it's a puzzle that needs to be
explained inflation explains that and
even more significantly inflation comes
up with a mechanism by which we can have
perturbations or fluctuations in the
universe without which you and I
wouldn't be here because it'd be no
reason for Gravity to condense to make a
Milky Way to make a star to make the
Earth Etc so those were the spectacular
successes flatness The Horizon the
magnetic and monopole and many other
solutions to different problems the the
the the problem is that inflation is not
really a theory there's no like one
theory of inflation ezrais would say
gravity or something gr even though
gravity has many alternatives to it will
hopefully cover those some other time
but the the fact is there's an infinite
number of inflationary models which
makes it so difficult to make a concrete
prediction that I as an experimental
astrophysicist can build an experiment
to test not to prove but to rule out and
that's what our job is our job is
experimentalists we should be
exterminators we should be killing as
many cockroach-like theories as possible
and what we're left with is the closest
approximation to truth yeah so why then
has there been these ideas which have
been around a long time Roger penrose's
conformal Theory and uh Paul Steiner's
pyroduct universe and bounces and brains
of b-r-a-n-e-s they've been around a
long time but they're suddenly having
more play yeah or more attention
is that a sociological phenomena I think
it's a response to the one kind of most
if you like the testable aspect of
inflation is is that it comes can
comatant with the Multiverse and many
people feel the Multiverse is not only
anathema to cosmology it's anathema to
the scientific method itself because
essentially anything that can happen in
the words of Alan Guth and Andre Linde
anything that can happen in a Multiverse
will happen in a Multiverse but look I
understand the challenge of the
Multiverse because anything that can
happen must happen and must happen an
infinite number of times that's just the
nature of infinity
so why was that upsetting people because
the the claim of the people who believe
in Multiverse is is that it is it is not
just a speculation but it's the natural
product the byproduct of the
inflationary Theory so what you'd like
as and I'm approaching this from an
experimental yeah okay I'd like a
concrete prediction that comes from a a
theory that is inductive right so I want
to be able to make some presumption that
what I'm measuring can say something
conclusively about the theory and the
underpinnings of what it's being deduced
from in that case uh it would be like
you know if in biology sometimes you you
have a double helix sometimes you have a
triple helix sometimes you have a Google
healing and so it would make it very um
it would be very almost unsatisfying in
a sense as at a very minuscule level of
importance uh that you measure any
particular result say the measurement of
the temperature of the microwave
background which we'll discuss uh but
the microwave background if it could be
anything it's much less powerful than if
I say it comes from a specific
condensation of a particular element and
that allows you more predictive power so
that's the problem that causes this
proliferation of alternatives to
inflation and as you said they're not
new I like to joke everything new is old
again because I look back into the into
the year you know search Google Scholar
for the year negative 1800 and you find
a cyclic cosmology in the Egyptian
hieroglyphs it's incredible this is
exactly like you know what we're talking
about Eastern religions have cyclicality
as their core aspect in fact they've
been opposed to Big Bang because it's
seeing seems to have a non-cyclicality
to it that was just a philosophical
objection that's right and as Stephen
Weinberg said you know the most
palatable thing about the steady state
model which was in Vogue in the 1960s
and 50s was that at least resembled
Genesis 1 1. he viewed that as a huge
philosophical virtue
um so so these these new models have
virtues but they also come with vices
too and what's been so interesting to me
as an experimentalist with no you know
kind of dog in this race uh of which
theory is right and actually my job is
to prove them all wrong and then that'll
probably be even more interesting is to
say what are the virtues what are the
vices and which ones can we make not
proofs of but definitive statements to
exclude portions thereof for example
inflation predicts a background of
gravitational radiation these other
models do not therefore measuring a
background of gravitational Cosmic
primordial gravitational waves not from
black holes in spiral into primordial
gravitational lines that would be
definitive disproof of the conformal
cyclic model of Sir Roger Penrose the
model of Ana Aegis and Paul steinhardt
called bouncing cosmological models the
pyrotic model of neural Turok and Paul
steinhardt etc etc so this is the string
gas cosmologies of Robert
brandenburger these would be exciting to
rule those out because we only have so
much time in the day in our life to
disprove different theories and
hopefully it gets us as you say closer
to truth and they they won't prove
Evolution correct they would pull its
Alternatives wrong which still which
maybe elevates inflation but still does
not prove it that's right they wouldn't
prove inflation wrong they would instead
exclude regions that could have been
true but are not